jaier M promised to transform Argentina
his criticism of corruption in the
political class struck a nerve with
Argentine struggling with soaring
inflation and on Sunday he won with over
55% of the
votes we want a limited government that
fulfills its promises respect of private
property and free trade the model that
generates decadence has come to an end
outside his headquarters thousands
celebrated M's Victory he has promised
to destroy the central bank and
dollarize the economy in a bit to fight
inflation this is our chance to think
long term because maybe with this
government there is hope but there are
many people human rights groups and
labor unions who are afraid that M's
radical economic reforms will come at
their expense mle has promised to
referendum on legal abortion to relax
gun control laws and austerity measures
that are likely to end up with violence
on the
streets I think it's sad my chest hurts
because this country is for everyone and
these people have no management have no
love for their neighbor and this hurts
it hurts a lot they have hate and we
have love and we wanted a country for
everybody kavier M has shocked Argentine
politics and his victory is the
beginning of a new era in
Argentina
people here say they're tired of living
in constant economic crisis and they
want to change kavier M has promised
some radical reforms in Argentina's
economy the question is whether he'll be
able to carry them out and at what
cost make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer